neutron stars Manhattan sized but with a
mass twice that of our
son so dense a teaspoon of their matter
weighs a billion
tons mindblowing objects that arrive
with a
bag neutron stars spark into life amid
the death of their parent star they are
the ultimate story story of Resurrection
or life from
Death it's all part of a cosmic
cycle Stars Are Born from giant clouds
of very cold gas those clouds collapse
under their own gravity and the density
of the core at the center of that
collapse starts to
[Music]
increase a star is a huge nuclear fusion
reactor the force of its gravity is so
powerful that it fuses atoms together to
make progressively heavier and heavier
elements the star fuses hydrogen into
helium once it exhausts its hydrogen
then if it's massive enough it can start
fusing helium at its
core Fusion continues forming carbon
oxygen
nitrogen all the way up to
iron once a star has iron in a core it's
almost like you've poisoned it because
this extinguishes the nuclear reactions
in the core of the star you fuse
something into iron and you get no
energy all of a sudden there's nothing
to support the crush of gravity no
radiation pressure pushing out means no
pressure keeping the outer regions from
falling in and that's what they do as
the star collapses in its Death Rows its
core becomes the wildest craziest and
freakiest pressure cooker in the whole
universe the ingredients are all in
place time to start cooking up a neutron
star if we were to scale up an atomic
nucleus to be the size of a baseball in
a normal atom the nearest electron would
be way over in those trees but in the
extreme conditions that lead to the
formation of a neutron star those
electrons can be pushed closer to the
nucleus they can come zipping in from
any direction and if the temperatures
and pressures are high enough they can
even strike the nucleus and enter it and
they can hit a proton and when they do
they become converted into more neutrons
so in the formation of one of these
objects the protons and electrons
disappear and you're left with almost
entirely pure neutrons with nothing to
stop them from cramming together and
filling up this entire baseball with
neutrons leading to incredibly High
densities with the Sea of electrons now
absorbed into the atomic nuclei the
matter and the Stars can now press
together a lot
tighter it's like squeezing 300 million
tons of mass into a single sugar
cube as the star collapses enormous
amounts of gas fall towards the
core the core is small in size but huge
in
Mass billions of tons of gas bounce off
of it then erupt into the biggest
fireworks display in the
cosmos a
supernova it's massive it's bright it's
imposing Supernova are among the most
dramatic events to happen in the
universe a single star dying one star
dying can outshine an entire
Galaxy and arising out of this cataclysm
a new and very strange Cosmic
entity When the Smoke finally clears
from the Supernova explosion you're left
with one of the most real fascinating
unbelievable monsters in the entire
universe humans have been witnessing
supernovas for thousands of years but
we're only now just starting to
understand what we've truly been with
witnessing the births of neutron
stars but while supernovas are big and
bright neutron stars are small and many
don't even give off
light so how many neutron stars are out
there we know of about 2,000 neutron
stars in our galaxy but there probably
are many many more I'm talking about
tens of millions in the Milky Way alone
and certainly billions throughout the
Universe
neutron stars may be small but some give
themselves away shooting beams Across
the Universe unmistakable pulsing
strobes of a cosmic
Lighthouse our knowledge of neutron
stars is expanding
fast but we didn't even know they
existed until a lucky Discovery just
over 50 years
ago Cambridge the mullard radio
Observatory Joselyn Bell grad student
operating the new radio telescope
scanning the sky doing all sorts of cool
astronomy stuff and sees what she calls
a bit of scruff in the
data this Scruff is a short but
constantly repeating burst of radiation
originating a thousand late years from
Earth it's so stable and regular that
Belle is convinced there's something
wrong with her telescope she returns to
that spot and finds a repeating regular
signal a single point in the sky that is
flashing at us continually saying hi hi
hi blip blip boom boom boom pulse pulse
pulse nothing that we know in the
universe has such a steady perfectly
spaced in time pulse it seems so perfect
that it must have been artificial it
looks like someone is making that but it
turns out it's not a person but a thing
what she discovered is called a
pulsar a pulsar is a type of rapidly
spinning neutron
star Neutron neutron stars had been
theorized in the
1930s but were thought to be too faint
to be
detected neutron stars were hypothesized
to exist but not really taken seriously
it was just uh oh that's cute maybe
they're out there but probably
not the signal Bell detected seemed like
something from science
fiction no one had ever seen this in
astronomy before and and some people
even speculated that it was an alien
signal she even called them lgm objects
Little Green
Men but then Belle found a second
[Music]
signal Little Green Men went back to
being fiction and pulsars became science
fact the discovery of pulsars came out
of the blue nobody was expecting this so
it was a an amazing breakthrough really
important
pulsars pulse because they're born to
spin they burst into life as their
parent star collapses during a
supernova any object at all that is
undergoing any sort of compression event
if it has any initial angular momentum
at all it will eventually end up
spinning as the star shrinks it spins
faster and faster
they spin so quickly because the
earth-sized core of a massive star
collapsed to something as small as a
city so because the size of the object
became so much smaller the rate of spin
had to increase by a tremendous
[Music]
amount